things you are starting to get back to
some form of normalization starting this
week
[Music]
your own carney thank you so much for
joining me on 20 minute
my pleasure thank you for having me
you're calling from israel right
i am how's everything over there things
you're
starting to get back to some form of
normalization starting this week
but it's way too early to wait to recess
i i myself am still at home yeah
well you know this is going to be
broadcasted in just a few weeks
so hopefully by then we'll keep on the
optimism and
and the starting to open up will be
fully opened up but we'll see
and let me doubt it but let's see we'll
see we'll see okay so you're on such a
great pleasure
and thank you so much founder of
maverick partners you're on the board of
some incredible
organizations that will touch upon a
contributor at forbes
i've been following for a long time and
a big fan and and i'd love to spend
these 20 minutes to sort of pick your
brain
and have a discussion on on what it what
it's like to open up
a venture capital firm in a pretty
non-traditional way
like you did while at the same time
really being
a core part of these organizations and
companies so maybe give me a quick
rundown of what happened in your life
that led to maverick
and then joining these awesome companies
so okay so that goes back to my
schooling i would i would assume
specifically
i studied i grew up in the states for a
bunch of years i'm israeli born grew up
in the states
and then moved back to israel to finish
high school do the army
and all that and then i started
studying uh here in israel at the
ibc at the zell program i was in the
second zone program
class wow and i just did a talk with a
liat aaron son i don't know if she was
the director back then
she wasn't she wasn't born then when i
when i was
uh and she's terrific she's a force
behind
the program for the past many many years
over a decade of course
anyhow uh so i studied there and i was
always an entrepreneur from a very young
age i can remember myself
really dabbling in every kind of
different
field that you could imagine i was
always attracted to setting up
companies and setting up businesses and
failing i failed a lot with a lot of
different
different ideas and a bit after
the my first degree my bachelor degree i
flew back to new york and i worked there
with my brother he had a
promotional staffing agency like hr
platform
at the time for independent contractors
that he had founded called gc marketing
and i
went back and helped him with the
company uh and
about a year later we found a
buyer who we sold the majority holdings
the company too and i decided to come
back home to israel yeah and i came back
and i was looking for what to do
and then um i was actually i started my
my master's degree in ip law
and i decided that i am very attracted
to the whole field of
[Music]
of technologies and was that really your
first
interception with technology when you
did your master's in ip
is that when you really got into it i
think i think during the zill program i
was most exposed to it and it actually
goes back the story
connects and you're even connected to it
to this story indirectly
um you yourself and
then i i decided i teamed up with
with a friend from new york who is a
very successful business person who i
met actually also
through my studies and he had sold his
company
in the states and he said you know what
let's start i keep hearing about israeli
innovation
let's start an angel group together in
which we will invest in very early stage
israeli companies
so i was it was basically you know
everyone has that moment in their life
that completely changes their life that
was my moment wow
and to this day it's probably my moment
and i remember that call and i
said all right great and i started
looking for startups to invest in
and i was you know i was um looking for
things for quite a long time and i
couldn't find anything that i really
liked
and so i this i thought at the time that
you know basically i'm screwed in a way
where this is just too difficult
to do and then out of nowhere i was very
very lucky
to have um to have been ex to have
remit my classmate from the zell program
or dead pontage
he had set up a company with um four
other founders
that was called la pixies
yeah that pixies did uh widgets for i
google i google is the equivalence of
say the app store nowadays but this was
a prehistoric
that's such a long time ago i remember
it from my childhood
exactly and that company uh i remember
it launched
and the first first day it made five
dollars and i thought wow this
is an amazing company because there's so
much potential
and we i ended up
convincing my partner to invest in it he
thought it was uh
you know he didn't really connect to it
as much and we put a million dollars in
the company i put a hundred thousand
dollars in the company which was
all i had from any you know it was all
the money i
had saved up and um yeah it was a long
journey and yeah yada yada
i also became the head of biz dev at the
company so i was both an
investor and interesting relatively
actively involved
yeah he also invested in six other six
companies in total
and that company lapixies ended being
ended up being the first israeli company
to be sold to google
wow met the uh the google guy
and he was based in the states at the
time
and uh we started talking and that led
to a relationship it was really amazing
uh
and then the deal was done very quickly
and it was really a true pleasure to
work with google
uh in this process and that at the time
made me quite known in the market
um and i got a lot of deal flow all of a
sudden right
as i mentioned earlier we we'd invested
in six companies
yeah uh two of them folded and four of
them we were able to sell
wow that was that's considered a very uh
you lucky track record yeah of course
and
and but i loved it i loved being able to
find entrepreneurs right at a very early
stage
i love being able to help them
you know with everything and anything
you could imagine really being one of
them as a founder
in a way so and so some of the companies
you know were still in touch of course
to this very day but some of them you
know we had all the growing pains that
they had suffered we'd gone through with
how tight was your relationship with
your with your founders and your first
investments
because you know it's all over the
spectrum some some investors like to be
very hands on some of them are very
you know talk to me every quarter what
was that extremely i mean daily
almost daily oh wow yeah um
at least several times a week um
nowadays by the way we're still very
actively involved as a fund
also the almost the same level of
intensity and because we believe that
that's what we could provide apart from
money
you know it's the added value component
but what i learned in the in
that angel group which was called the
tel aviv angel group
is the importance of of working with
your
investors and getting as much added
value from them as possible because
everybody
has the ability to be helpful to the
companies they just need to be prone
to to be helpful totally you know that's
the point totally and you need to know
how to
to motivate them and how to get their
attention and all these people even
though
likely this won't change their
lifestyles if the company does
incredibly well
they still want to be helpful and they
find the the companies
interesting both in an economic
perspective but also
you know challenging um in other forms
and out of interest they like to be
helpful to the companies because they
find what they're doing interesting
right so what is that what is maverick
actually what does that name stand so
maverick
maverick actually sort of is the next
generation
right step of of the ma of the tel aviv
angel group that i've founded
and ma the word maverick was chosen
because of the dual meaning of you all
know what a maverick means in english
but in hebrew
maverick means ark to shine
to be you know a genius idea
and that's what that that's the the
origin of this name so we are maverick
ventures israel that's the name of the
fund
uh we have um two funds our first fund
was just a bit over 40 million dollars
the second fund was over 75 million
dollars wow
and now we um are in the process of
uh fundraising for our third fund
wonderful so how many companies have
invested in so far
we've invested in 35 companies i believe
last year was very very active i think
we were one of the most active funds if
not the
uh in israel but we don't tend to uh
promote uh any of the deals that we do
we're not against it if other firms do
but we are so or the company does but we
ourselves
relatively shy away from uh proactive
public relations at this time until god
willing we
succeed in one of the companies
something interesting happens with one
of the companies then we're very happy
but
our approach is to try to be relatively
as modest as we can at this stage
so give me maybe you know two or three
very quick
um intuitions that you're looking for as
you're
as you're approaching due diligence but
i'm assuming this is more seed stage
right
now we don't we do early growth earlier
check size is usually
up to five million dollars tomorrow two
to five million dollars is our uh
so i no longer do the the stuff i did
with the angel group
we try to go we we only look for
companies that already have
initial traction and revenue and we try
to help them scale up as much as we can
we have over a hundred investors a
hundred lps so
what i had before and the four to six
investors in the angel group so this is
the same thing
much bigger and all these people as i
said some of them are extremely helpful
you probably know several of them and
they are people that come from all
fields from academia
from different businesses we have
business women and men from really all
walks of life that you could imagine
so what what are some of the challenges
of running a fund with over a hundred
lps because
on one hand you want to really utilize
their their strong
backgrounds and their expertise whether
it's in due diligence or in deal
sourcing
but at the same time you sort of have to
please a hundred different people and
you know they're saying you put two jews
right two jews in a room you get six
opinions so i can't imagine what i'm not
jews by the way they're not only jewish
people thank god
there's people from all walks of life
and all all ethnicities and all
backgrounds
and happily the people who invest in
maverick don't invest in africa because
of the say ethnical aspect of it being
you know
jewish homeland and so on they just
think it's a place that they could
get a high return and then how do you
balance
how do you balance this expectation that
you'll please everybody
while at the same time never please
anybody you never please anybody but you
need to first of all you need to do a
few things
first and foremost and i say this to
every person who wants to become an lp
in the company
i bluntly tell them there's a very good
chance you'll lose
all your money investing in a venture
fund and in our venture fund it makes
sense yeah as well
secondly we try we don't try to please
them what we do try to do
is to do everything possible to reach
the best outcome we can
and to be a go-between between their
abilities
and and their connections and what the
companies seek
so each one of these investors in our
our mindset
has the ability to be helpful to each
one of the companies to many of the
companies
people who have gone through like
imagine you in 10 years from now
you know you will have your alumni
association you'll have all the
all the friends that you've had your
past jobs and
education and so on and so forth and
you'd like to be helpful to the
companies but you'd also like us to be
as respectful to your time as possible
so we need to keep to make sure that we
know exactly what each person could
bring to the table
on one hand and on the other hand not to
assume that you do not have connections
to a juice manufacturer in australia
because maybe you randomly do
and so we try to sort of you know play
on that thin line and be still very
respectful to the
to the lp's time and the way we do this
is we send a quarterly report and then
we have a to do page
uh at the very beginning with what with
three points that each company
uh would like assistance with so
interesting
say staffing a position like a cf
they're looking for cfo
to open an office on the east coast or
they
want uh you know a connection to this or
that conglomerate
or as anybody has you know experience in
a specific
tax question that they may have and and
you will just
notice that oftentimes people have
something to add
and that's what differentiates us we act
interesting with the same passion that
we had as an angel group
i want to believe we have the same thing
now and when it's people's private money
it's different than it when you're of
course when you have raised money from
institutionals
and again of course not all the lps are
you know very active but
many of them surprise you of course yeah
no i have to say that you know
i'm a part i'm way with a dead now at j
ventures and i and we also
i'm a great guy yeah over 100 lps and
it's just so
humbling to see that you know people are
people are putting their time their
effort and i keep and it's amazing how
much how much of it they put in
and how willingly they want to help and
when it's not you know for a salary or
or because they have to but because they
want to they raise their hand and say
yeah i want to be a part of this
of this company and this due diligence
or this or helpless portfolio
you see so much value that they bring
and and you're right that out of
over a hundred potential lps you some
you sometimes get these gems
that are really random with a connection
to a juice manufacturer in australia
your own i have to ask about it united
salad group
and one of the most inspiring
organizations and entrepreneurship
elements of israel talk to me a little
bit about it and what's your role over
there
i will just before i get into that i
want to go back one step and say that
our lps are from all over the place and
thank thank god really one of the best
things to have happened to remember we
said there's that moment when i got that
phone call from my first partner
yeah and uh in the angel group and then
this the second moment that i had
was when i met who michelle abadi was my
partner and has been my partner since
the inception of the fund
of maverick uh he is originally from
brazil he lives in israel though now for
over 16 years
and his network spans of latin america
which is a humongous
area that people tend to forget yeah you
know when it comes to this field
and we have investors from europe and
from australia and from other parts of
the world
so uh very heterogeneous in terms of of
the backgrounds of the
amazing and of course i have really and
him and i michelle and i
really complement each other and we work
very well together
that's something very important if i
could give one tiny advice to all the
aspiring new people watching if there's
anyone watching that's
you know wants to set up a company of
any kind is to always make sure
to do the what is considered
counter-intuitive which is
to not surround yourself by people that
have the same backgrounds as yeah that
you know from school
his background he's an engineer by trade
he's a banker
he um we're very different
and we are very very close and really
complimentary wonderful
wonderful uh about this so so going back
to the fact that we have only private
investors one of the second reason
the second reason we only have private
investors the first of course is their
potential added value which has proven
itself time and time again
is the fact that we decided from the
get-go to donate
two percent of our funds um carry
of the success of the fund to united
hatsala which you mentioned united hotel
in my opinion
is the most amazing organization that
i've come across and i think that it
embodies two things that are important
to me and to everyone which is again
entrepreneurship
because what they do is very innovative
what they've decided to go against
the flow yeah and secondly is the very
basic essence of saving lives
take action into their own hands what's
that
taking action into their own hands
literally bypassing
waiting for anyone else and what they do
they started as a
guerrilla operation in a way and to them
too i was introduced by that same
partner mark arson from the very
beginning
and what they do is they formed an
organization which is
similar to uber if you think about it
yup which is an organization that has
over 6 000 volunteers spread out
throughout all of israel
and these are people that go around
their day-to-day jobs or
whatever they're doing and they have
they are located they all have medical
training and equipment and they uh
first responders first to get to the
first responders
stabilize whoever is injured
car accidents births um heart attacks
stabbings terror attacks god willing god
forbid and
all these other things and uh they get
to
1800 calls a day 1800 calls a day yeah
yep and it's all for free they'll never
charge anything from anyone
ever they also have a few ambulances to
help transport people who
just can't play are not able or not
willing to pay
uh for transport hospitals and all
these and and they just do good they
have people who help
with um psychiatric help and
psychological help and they they help
holocaust survivors they help the needy
they are basically
a bunch of angels that uh it's the most
amazing organization i've done and by
the way
similar to startup you want to make sure
that their
the money that goes into them is spent
in a lean manner
of course and that's and that's
something that you could see there money
there goes
the vast vast majority of it to buying
medical supplies
so you're you're not just you're not
just a fan you're you're on the board of
of the united states on the board for
the past over a decade
incredible uh there are many wonderful
people and
um i've decided in my uh
you know start of philanthropic life too
to only focus on one thing and to do it
as well as you can
and every single person that i meet i
introduce and praise and talk about this
organization because this organization
is the essence of being a lie down to
the nations which is what the jewish
people are called to be
and this is organization that we're
trying to set up all over the world
this isn't a jewish thing here we are we
we have
many many muslims and many many
christians
which is all ultra orthodox totally
secular people
and we're doing the same thing all over
the world where we want people to copy
this we want
this i myself was in brazil when they
opened it
lithuania new jersey jersey city
um and other parts of the world and this
is exactly what we want we want israeli
this is our
exit of a startup company we want this
to go global to go global i love it
millions of lives i love it your own i
can't believe we're already over 20
minutes
it went by way way too fast i have to
put you on the spot once
and uh and ask you for three words that
you would best describe yourself
or that others would describe you
whether it's michelle
or ellie baer from united salah what are
three words that would really
embrace your own kearney annoying
good funny
and a good friend i love it to these two
people
i love it your own thank you so so much
stay safe stay healthy thank you for the
inspiration thank you so much
thank you